peut-être globalement dans les prisons
vous avez deux types de travail vous
avez travaillé pour l'entretien de la
prison les repas un petit peu de
nettoyage
et puis vous avez la possibilité
travaillé pour des entreprises privées
qui ont d'aider des contrats de
partenariat avec la prison mais sont
payés à un taux horaire équivalent à
entre 20 et 40 100 du smic ce qui
correspond à entre 1 euro 92 et 4 euros
net de l'heure
l'observatoire international des prisons
dénoncent régulièrement cette situation
depuis depuis plusieurs années en disant
que le travailleur en détention doit
pouvoir être considéré comme un
travailleur comme les autres et je pense
que en effet ça doit être le cas il faut
travailler là dessus on a pas moyen de
faire travailler on pourrait avoir des
contrats ou bien n'a pas les moyens
informatiques ont effectivement il ya
des contrats des contrats on peut dire
que c'est un peu des contrats mots
certains engagent mois de travail la
pénitentiaire
à la base il est fait pour les personnes
qui sont indigents c'est la perte est en
effet trop en priorité pour les
personnes qui ne reçoivent pas de mandat
qui n'ont pas de famille compagnonnage
qui se font en ce moment dans la
pauvreté dans l'établissement je précise
quand même que un détenu qui n'a pas
d'appoint il mange il avait l'âge
l'abbaye là elle est pas dans les termes
en q1 en train de faire les détenus
étaient aux mains pures il ya 40 ans en
arrière
la problématique sur le travail c'est
que rabat des tenues aussi deux
victoires une de leurs victimes
malheureusement respectent pas forcément
voir quasiment pas du tout cet
engagement là ils respectent pas les
gros pourcentages on va pas dire tout le
monde ce serait maintenant au tac mais
fait pas le cas
on va augmenter ce qui gagne aujourd'hui
pour pouvoir quoi bon aller d'accès ou
alors parce que c'est quoi leur boîte un
peu dire que derrière compass quelque
chose moi je veux dire contact pourquoi
pas et je savais où on ignore le
gouvernement aujourd'hui il ya quand
même des choses si on augmente et le
gabon détenue au montant s'avère les
d'études pourquoi pas aussi le travail
moi je veux bien mais tout ça et vous
les moyens propre et un tiers pour voir
si tu fumes un bar mette en oeuvre
maintenant au niveau du scanner bon
choix qu'est squat accès au web je me
pose la question
ou alors mon agent je suis pas je suis
pas friand de ce qui a été annoncé il ya
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites et
son contraire on voit surtout les
personnes qui reprenait tout ça sont
loin de l'administration pénitentiaire
on n'est ce pas le entourer ces
relations de travail de règles plus
précises et notamment les soumettre au
code du travail
ça à mon sens davantage fondamentale la
prison est là pour sanctionner même si
là pour réinsérer et je crois que tant
que l'on pousse bien râler détenus je
parle concernant le travail comme des
gens qui restent en dehors de la société
qui n'ont pas des fiches de paye
toujours
j'en ai une devant les yeux ki moon qui
n'ont pas les filles
et comme toujours tu ne cotise pas comme
tout le monde y compris pour leurs
droits
c'est à dire aujourd'hui détenu ne
cotisent pas à tous qu'un accident du
travail maladie c'est à dire que s'il en
accident du travail n'est pas pris en
charge par la sécurité sociale
ça pose des questions de réinsertion de
psychologie en prison est là pour
essayer de battre
dans la société d'état parce qu'il
cotait et délits ça c'était la
progression la deuxième chose et
monsieur je suis parfaitement d'accord
avec vous il ya un problème de moins et
un pointe de moyens parce que si
aujourd'hui il ya que 28 à 30 août sont
des détenus qui travaillent c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de travail en détention et on
en revient toujours au même
malheureusement quand on parle
aujourd'hui de la justice et de la
pénitentiaire
c'est une question d'argent qu'est ce
que ça changerait je vois les choses
c'est que s'il est fait opérer pour
pouvoir conquérir ces trois et ils vont
pouvoir comprend et c'est pendant
dernier le renouveau on vire parfois au
roulement et à l'investiture sont pas
adéquates pour moi d'avoir combiné
encore une fois où il m'a dit mon corps
et ça va et bien sûr ça crée du contenu
moi je jory désespoir j'attends de voir
le projet complet en revanche je trouve
que l'idée est bonne et c'est surtout
une idée qui a germé depuis de
nombreuses années notamment au sein de
l'observatoire international des prisons
moi ce que je crois surtout c'est que
moralement et socialement il ya beaucoup
d'intérêt à cela et bien entendu il ya
un intérêt économique
on dit souvent des détenus qui y
participent jeanne a rien qui payent
rien et cetera
le fait qu'il soit soumis au code du
travail et qu'ils aient des fiches de
paye qu'ils cotisent à tous dont les
salariés normaux entre guillemets
cotisent
je trouve que un moment donné c'est
aussi participer à la société c'est
faire société